I've debated doing this when I was
pinned down by a sniper in Afghanistan
but there's no way that enemy sniper
would have hit that though my name is
Nicholas Irving I'm a former US Army
Ranger Special Operation Sniper I'm
command sergeant major retired Lamont
Christian I'm Nicholas morren my name is
dakata Brody hey everyone Jay Lee here
hi I'm John Spencer got of Tim's here
I'm a former raw Marines commando today
I'm back again to look at some more
sniper scenes from TV in film rage tank
battles Urban Warfare desert Warfare
scenes boot camp scenes helicopter
rescue scenes bomb disposal scenes in
movies and TV and judge how real they
are and always answer every question
with yes drill sergeant is that clear
yes Drill Sergeant the standard for
responding to a drill sergeant is yes
drill sergeant no drill sergeant and if
it has to have an affirmative response
then the whole platoon will s sound just
like that in 10 hours let what you
spends on
gas Sergeant Jesus H Christ this is a
new company record the drill sergeant
was so impressed because you know in the
early part of training it's a challenge
for somebody who perhaps has not handled
a weapon before what we would call
weapons training to be able to take that
weapon apart put it back together and do
what you saw Forest do there which was
that functions check what your hope is
as a DI or drill sergeant
is that everybody in there can do it
like for us shrimping potatoes shrimp
burger what's funny is when they're in
there with them with toothbrushes that's
something of the past it was times where
uh you know you give a recruit scissors
and say go cut the grass they're
fostering this environment of working
together as a team what you saw with the
weapons training which is what I call
Mindless repetition just do it over and
over and over again until you get it
right that has the same training effect
that this used to have the approach that
the drill sergeant had in here was very
very common for that time period during
the Vietnam war so that's about a nine
pick it up move it Mo it I want to see
some fire
here when you look at uh obstacle
courses usually in boot camp you'll go
through them twice obstacle courses are
really designed to find your upper body
strength and also determine your
endurance and so it may even test your
fear of high
um fear of darkness and then you get to
actually experience the teamwork helping
each other you saw that a couple of
times in there and definitely that
screaming and yelling often we call it
simulating you know Battlefield
conditions Loop this is the rabbit hole
the rabbit comes out of his hole what is
interesting is ropes and not tying is no
longer taught in basic training it is in
Rangers school though you're actually
tested in the mountain phase as things
uh change over time there's certain
requirements that the leaders think that
people need Upon finishing basic
training this is to be your lover your
mistress your concubine perhaps the only
thing in life you'll ever truly love
that's one of those things again that
you get from TV and Hollywood where we
placed all of this uh level of intimacy
with our weapon now granted it is an
intimate relationship because you really
want to be confident with that weapon so
taking it apart putting it together um
almost to the point you can do it
blindfolded right talk about it in a way
that might be sexual that's kind of a
Hollywood thing that happens well I'm
sorry
Sergeant I can't touch a gun for that
time period being World War II being a
conscientious obor was going to
definitely be a challenge for the
leadership here this guy particularly is
uh Desmond Doss he was actually a Medal
of Honor recipient and he didn't have to
carry a weapon to do it I would
definitely say this was was a nine on
realism can't think while I'm giving you
a few love Taps how the are you going to
fire your rifle when grenades are going
off in your
face you know unfortunately what we wind
up running into a lot of times is drill
sergeants or dis like this one that will
touch and and grab by the throat that
was familiar in other you know di movies
touching recruits and in uh training is
unacceptable always has been
sir I got lost on the way to college
sir that's exactly why right there the
open door that I could do even more and
it turns to him slamming the kids head
into a wall and and that's why it's
unacceptable because where do you draw
the line them paintball bullets they
hurt you paintball is something as you
notice it's pretty painful that guy uh
is going to learn a valuable lesson not
to put himself in a window if he's going
to engage engage and so that that's why
paintball uh simunitions is kind of what
we call it is very very useful in the
training environment sounds that you are
hearing a live round you will get the
fear out of you
keep that's a trainer a sergeant a
Leader's worst nightmare is to have
somebody in training uh lose their life
shooting the rounds over their head um
we actually do that and we also do it at
night but the conditions are totally
different the the guns are are raised up
a whole lot higher as and it's what we
call a a safe surface zone so even if
you stood up or jumped up and down it's
almost 20 ft above the heads of the
individuals and again this tragedy right
here as unfortunate as it is um it does
happen when those things are not adhere
to for a boot camp movie uh is probably
about a
five
Rusty bayonet Le
got now thanks to these men and their
infractions every man in the company who
hired a weekend pass has lost it this is
pretty neat because U I actually served
as the command sergeant major for this
unit for the second Battalion 506
parachute infantry regimen out of the
101st Airborne this right here is easy
company and their preparation for World
War II during that time period in our
military not many people were married
right and everybody was always looking
for a two-day or a 3-day pass the stuff
that they being inspected on like this
parade level stuff and they're out there
in combat gear I could see where he's
going but trying to instill discipline
just uh I'm sure morale is not going to
be too high much
longer do not help that man do not help
bman we ran this mountain a couple of
times Curry he Mountain yeah it's no
joke uh what I noticed here though you
know he was telling them to leave that
guy not leaving our fallen comrade you
know that was part of the warrior ethos
and never quitting so when you tie that
together in today's modern military uh
leaving somebody behind would be
something that we wouldn't do that would
be a 10 for running up that hill and for
World War II uh it probably be about an
eight in
realism and no drill sergeant do I make
myself clear yes drill sergeant you get
them in the barber chair spin them
around they had no hair like that's even
part of like a military Cadence
sometimes or males anyway are getting
their haircut where they cut it all the
way down female recruits are not
required and believe it or not it's a
health and hygiene issue right because
you get people that come from all walks
of life and so you don't know
necessarily if they have like headlights
or any other type of uh issues
underneath all the hairs next we got
about 100
shots just get shot until you get all
the way to the end and you're completely
inoculated against every disease known
to man
right
execute the difference that I could see
so far in this scene is they have them
all taking their clothes off like in an
open room or an open Bay it wouldn't be
done that way at the what they call a
military entrance processing station or
the MEPS all military members go through
there and there's no drill sergeants
there right it's it's just a staff of
military personnel administrators
doctors counselors because what they're
doing is they're determining whether or
not you're fit to train had a strip down
to our underwear and duck walk the
circuit of a big
room oh yeah duck walking I remember the
first time I did that I was like what in
the world they have you walk from one
side of the room to the other and the
doctor is looking for your bone
structure your muscular skeletal uh
development if you're flat footed also
just your mobility and Agility but yeah
you definitely wouldn't be in a room
like that full of other people be hard
to assess I would have to say it's about
a four right because that's not
necessarily how that whole
indoctrination process would happen with
the drill sergeants if you survive
recruit training you will be a weapon
you will be a minister of death praying
for war so far this is looking pretty
good in the DI in the Marine Corps um
they actually have a script they say you
up straight and look at me so while the
difference in the titles the drill
instructors was tied into the Marine
Corps drill sergeants became into play
for the Army and the interaction in the
first part of boot camp is always going
to be what we call Total Control
everywhere you look there's going to be
some di or drill sergeant ensuring that
the training that has been given um is
being reinforced and so when you see uh
R Le Army walking around in the bay he's
doing exactly what a DI would do he
actually was a drill sergeant as a
matter of fact uh he served several
years during the Vietnam War as a DI
maggots understand that sir sir can't
hear you sir if you notice the DI is
constantly yelling and it's not because
they like yelling at individuals it's
just that they don't have to repeat the
same commands over and over so if you
have a a recruit on one end of the Bay
uh he or she is going to hear the
instructions all the way on the other
end of the bay N I didn't know they
stack that high you trying to squeeze an
itch in on me somewhere H another thing
that you often see in these movies and
TV shows is the DI or the drill sergeant
doing a lot of cursing and swearing
cursing and swearing is not something
that is acceptable but but it does
happen for that Vietnam era that's
pretty realistic now you have people who
are deciding to you know serve their
country and it's a different view I was
part of the committee that created the
change what we called Shock and Awe
commonly called a shark attack as
opposed to this fallacy which was we
have to break them down in order to
build them up and focus more on the
teamwork and so that's what the 100
yards was designed to do day one here's
a
challenge pop that
ler part of that indoctrination when the
DI comes in is the wellness of the
trainees or the recruits and so they
have to inspect the feet they inspect
the hands and make sure that there's no
open
source what the is
that what is that private pile sir jelly
donut sir we've gone away from Foot
Lockers and uh modularized most of the
equipment in the bay so you wouldn't
necessarily have a Foot Locker in the
bay and they definitely wouldn't be
standing on the equipment like that they
have this term in the army they call
Total Line L and that's where they
actually stand next to the line so that
they can do that inspection from now on
whenever private
pile I will not punish him I will punish
all of you yep there we
go especially in the beginning phases of
boot camp the DI and the drill sergeant
is going to definitely Dole out
punishment as a mass punishment even
though one person may mess up this
opportunity for somebody to have looked
and held pile accountable for that donut
was missed and that's what the DI is
reinforcing we hold each other
accountable I would have to say it was
probably about a nine for that era uh if
we're talking in today's terms it
probably be about a seven in realism we
are going to win this war because we
have the best
men when they were standing formation
and the leader stopped and kind of
looked at this guy he looks like a
middle middle school kid there was
actually a guy named named uh flaty this
guy was 4' 9 in and they called him the
Giant Killer because of all the
different exploits that he did during
Vietnam and he was smaller than than
Rogers was right nobody's got that flag
in 17
[Music]
[Applause]
years yo the smallest guy right in the
formation wound up coming up with the
plan of success in the basic training
environment you probably wouldn't have
that type of situation placed on a
trainee or a recruit that's some special
missions type unit uh stuff that's going
on there where an assessment is being
done right because they want to know if
you have a special skill set what they
were actually doing in the training
would would not necessarily be something
that you would see in recruit training
so I'm going give it a
five
PE yeah that's the campaign hat or the
the famous drill sergeant hat I just
happen to have mine with me and uh you
know there distinct take here that is
worn by the male drill sergeants in the
Army um but then also by the male and
female di in the Marines what's unique
is uh while all the branches except the
Navy has some form of a campaign hat um
the Army still has a separate hat for
the female drill
it's called a a bush
[Music]
hat that part where the one character
starts singing that you know Diddy Bop
it's interesting that most cadences
that's actually where they come from
right popular Tunes R&B music I mean
even nursery rhymes even my own voice
has been tapped into a Cadence and uh
the Gatorade commercial singing the hard
work
Cadence so these guys they're just you
know jumping in on a bandwagon throwing
in the Diddy Bop in there at the same
time Raaz dazle
2 2 yeah that ain't
happening however uh in the Army in what
we call the advanced individual training
which those periods of training go from
6 weeks to 6 months maybe even a year
drill and ceremony competitions are
usually used to continue to motivate
those individuals that have the longer
periods of training but not as likely in
a basic combat training cuz we're
focusing on shooting moving
communicating and treating yourself and
others on the battlefield I'd have to
say a four locate a wounded
soldier represented by dummy you must
then transport him to the emergency
field Hospital there's a lot going on
there so far when it started out it it
definitely was something that you would
see in recruit training you know a lot
of female leaders now are in positions
of senior leadership uh that something
that hadn't occurred over many years
until the military had started really
opening up the ranks of the Infantry to
our female leaders an aggressor team
will be trying to stop you they are all
awaiting ranger training and can't wait
to capture
you based on what the information and
the instructions they were given is
actually um an advanced individual
training you know medical training
they're not going to be as complex with
a mission that would go that deep and
that was evident when I saw them in the
river there because the risk for you
know perhaps somebody drowning or you
know something else with all that
equipment on and not too many people are
going to want to put a recruit in that
type of environment
[Music]
again the risk factors uh wouldn't be
something that you'd see in recruit
training but uh definitely something
very similar challenging wise as far as
the uh military is concerned you know
Marines have a crucible and the Army has
this thing called the forge very similar
in the final test of all of the training
that they received during the recruit
training in their medical Lanes where
they might have to treat a casualty or
transport a casualty like you saw here
to really see if all of the training has
actually reached uh the the point where
they are confident that these
individuals can leave and go to their
next assignment I have to give that a
five as far as
realism
of hazing is something that again has
never been uh accept it but uh it
happens this is depicting an environment
where there still initial entry training
or initial military training uh but it's
officer candidate School typically
officer candidates are a little bit more
mature uh H have either been in the
military for quite some time and reached
enlisted ranks there's levels of hazing
that may be more acceptable uh in that
environment versus in the recruit
training so there was a mandate that
provided leadership across all of the
branches to come up with you know
Progressive ways if you would in order
to attack and get in front of hazing and
so whether it was uh reporting such as
in the Army you know not in my squad to
place accountability not just on
leadership um but on each other go Ser
do I ain't going to quit all right then
you can forget it you're out don't you
do it there's about two or three layers
of checks and balances so that you don't
have that Rogue di or Rogue drill
sergeant who might take something
personal like it looks like in this clip
because of the flexibility and the
things that uh take place in the office
of candidate School versus what happens
in um recruit training for initial entry
training I would say uh that it's a
probably about a
seven all right surely you can drop them
now weight training has always been
something that's important in the
military to be able to carry your body
weight and in some cases you might have
to lift or carry or drag somebody else
the sand buckets and them using them for
weights a lot less expensive than buying
weights for every Marine but then they
get the same physical exercise out of it
outside get into the body once again
working with the but
the you know they were doing combatives
right with the pugal and and the the
drill instructor was showing them with
the knife close quarter combat because
every Marine every Soldier uh every
person that joins the military is is a
fighter first right and so pugal train
training is one of those ways that that
confidence is instilled in the
individual uh in their ability to stand
their ground and it's also fun to look
at I I would say it's a about a seven
greetings all I'm Nicholas Moren I
commissioned as an armor officer for M1
tanks and then converted to M3 br
these days I work as a civilian vehicle
historian primarily for World of
[Music]
Tanks the ripsaw which was basically a
tracked toy for people to drive around
in looks just like it does in the movie
here because it had such lightweight and
such a high powered weight ratio the
thing is incredibly fast and Incredibly
Nimble which of course attracts the
attention of the military hang on a
second we got this vehicle that can go
anywhere really really quickly can we do
something with it but the variant that
the Army has been looking at of late is
actually a robotic combat vehicle I
believe it's the RCV M and it's being
plugged as the M5 and on the top much
like is shown in the clip is a remote
Weapon
[Music]
Station he's driving on ice and those
don't look like ice tracks Believe It or
Not There is actually ways he can get
more grip on a track vehicle on Ice it's
uh anything from snow chains that was
used in World War II to these days you
can have Growers that you knock out a
few track pads and you put basically
cleats in into the track this thing is
going quite fast doing its various
Maneuvers on ice and that's questionable
in this
context
I can think of no reason except for an
accession to plot why a tank would have
a grappling hook attached to it the
lambo at the point that they connect is
basically underwater and that provides
more drag than this thing can can haul
well there's your point of realism the
door came off instead of the lambo
getting pulled out I'm going to be
generous I'm going to give it one point
because it has tracks and I'm going to
give it one point because it pulled a
door instead of the whole Lambo so I'm
going to give it a two
so you will have seen the Americans had
somebody standing on the back firing the
caliber 50 the caliber 50 was originally
put onto American Vehicles as an
anti-aircraft weapon and the reason that
it's on that external mount mount at the
back is that it's a lot easier to aim
upwards if you're standing on the back
deck and then aiming up as opposed to
trying to stick your head out of the
hatch and maybe put it down from the
side you're not even able to use the
sights one of the things Sherman was
very good at was showing up when you
needed a tank and they tended not to go
around in ones and twos they tended to
go around in fives and 17s yeah sure on
a tank on tank duel it wasn't
necessarily the best for an infantryman
that's under heavy attack he doesn't
care if the best tank in the world shows
up as long as a tank which shows up a
actually arrives and B is good enough to
deal with whatever the infantryman's
problem
is so you will notice that the Germans
don't actually have any tanks which was
a problem that the Germans had in World
War II is that their industry simply
wasn't up to the levels of American or
Russian so what we have here are a lot
of assault guns and tank destroyers that
looks like a martyr there at least a
representation of one a stumer shuts
which is an assault gun and a egg
Panther the egg Panther is the only one
that is the serious threat to an Allied
vehicle why doesn't the a panther just
sit there and place its extremely
frontal armor to the Shermans well you
could do that but then you're probably
now placing your weak flank armor to the
American infantry who are equipped in
the scene with Bazookas anti-tank rocket
launchers the Germans are now out
flanked and so very sensibly they
immediately abandon the attack and start
falling back this is as good as you're
going to get on C lloy or digits if
there is ever going to be a 10 for rate
a tank battle this is probably
it
the tanks represent s shamal there's
only one that exists in the world it's
at the French national tank Museum in
samour now the cogniz Senti will look at
the road wheels on that and realize that
the vehicle is based off of a BMP or an
mtlb which are Soviet cold war vehicles
open by this point in the war it's that
we're talking towards the end of 198 the
Germans are very familiar with tanks but
you'll still want to shoot them anyway
for a couple of reasons one is if the
tanks are accompanying infantry well
you're going to have an effect on the
Infantry and maybe suppress them to the
point that the tanks are going to
advance on their own secondly the tanks
were not the most robust at the time
there was a problem known as Splash
especially in World on the tankers would
actually wear a type chain mail in front
of their face with goggles to stop the
pieces of bullet coming in the gaps in
the armor finally it's psychological it
makes you feel a lot better uh to
actually do something even if it's a
gesture of
futility the early tank guns for World
War I would generally either been
converted artillery pieces or quite
often Naval guns the big problem you're
going to have with getting up close is
called depression so there is a stop as
to how far down the gun will depress and
that tell determines how close you can
get to the enemy trench before you can
uh have to stop engaging it
to this date trench Crossing ability in
terms of meters how many meters of
trench you can cross is still a
Criterion the idea of can you cross it
without collapsing it well that depends
if you want to collapse it or not so
even as late as the Iraq campaigns a
tank would go up to fortified enemy
position turn on the spot and bury the
people inside and it's one of those
unfortunate realities that basically
tanks have many ways of killing you and
the tracks are one of
them you think today a handang grenade
isn't going to do very much the tracks
on the San shiman were basically from a
Hal tractor so they weren't as battle
prooof as a modern vehicle would be in
fact the armor on this is so thin that a
lot of heavy bullets uh they even
developed rifle bullets with an
armor-piercing core could go through
these early tanks this is an8 and half
maybe nine just I could quibble a few
things but it generally gets the concept
across Oh
goodie so Rambo has gotten into
his I'm going to call it a t72 it's not
actually but the helicopter here
represents a hind I think it's actually
a puma but the the hind the Mi 24 was a
a gunship that still actually has the
troop carrying capacity as well is
carrying a lot of rockets and missiles
and being heavily armored it's basically
a flying tank for lack of a better
[Music]
term so hang on is is he driving or is
he gunning there's only one tank that I
can think of that is fully combat
capable with one crewman and that is the
Swedish strv 103 commonly known as the S
tank the driver functions as the Gunner
as well and this is why you're supposed
to go with anti-aircraft vehicles in
company with you because their job is to
defend you against air
threats so our enemy is in a an attack
helicopter a gunship and it's got
missiles on the tips 82 swatters
probably that are effective from several
kilometers away and instead he is firing
unguided rockets at the front of the
Rambo tank why doesn't he just fly
around the back and shoot the Rockets
into the engine deck or the rear turret
or some you know some place that'll
actually cause
[Music]
damage and so the enemy pilot dies to
death that his stupidity would deserved
officially if you must charge towards an
aircraft do it at an angle he has to not
only aim for lead but also the change in
distance at the same time whereas if
you're charging straight at him you're
simplifying the problem for the aircraft
that's coming at you he doesn't need to
worry about aiming it has a tank so I'll
give it a
one the premise of an ambush in an urban
setting by armor is not unheard of but
the idea of arm armor operating in an
urban setting without infantry support
is normally questionable Panthers are
not well suited for close range fighting
they really would Excel on the Eastern
front on the steps of Ukraine for
example with nice long lines of fire
that said they can get away with it in
this context because they know that the
enemy is a single tank with no
infantry oh look he's going through a
building again except this time he's
done one thing right he's got the turret
traversing over the rear I'd mentioned
before you don't want to go through a
building if you can avoid it in this
case I guess they couldn't because
they're getting shot at and if you are
going to go through spin your turret
over and you'll you'll keep yourself
safe and what you can see here the t3485
has a very neat Traverse handle so it
performs two functions in this case you
can see he has it in manual mode
cranking around as opposed to Electric
mode which you simply flip the handle
90° however maybe the Gunner just
doesn't know this because in the movie
this was a found tank even myself when I
got into a t3485 for the first time and
trying to see where is the second
control handle I can't find
it this is quite feasible when fac with
the panther with this close-range t-34
crew now has a choice it can either run
away or it can attempt to engage now I
would probably agree with the 34 crew on
this for two reasons one the panther was
looking the wrong way entirely and the
other thing is Panthers are not the
easiest thing in the world to kill
unless he can get around the side or
behind them and in this case they're
already behind them so why not engage
but the only thing I might have done
differently was back up two or three
tank lengths and aim the gun into the
engine de deck that would uh be a more
guaranteed kill than trying to aim for
the turret
ring so the explosion is actually a
little bit faster than would really
happen generally speaking when a tank is
hit it takes a couple of seconds and
those are your couple of seconds that is
the difference between life and death
when you're getting out of a vehicle
although in reality the net effect
difference to the creu
is academic they're they're basically
toast in this context uh I don't know
maybe a
seven the movie is set about the time of
the ameni Civil War which is actually
kind of still ongoing the film was made
in Morocco hence you have the
m60sbs it gets the point across
certainly there are Western and Eastern
tanks in the
area so what I have here is a Vic 1 CVC
combat vehicle crewman helmet and the
reason you would want to wear a helmet
even if you're inside the tank is quite
simply you're being thrown around
there's a lot of sharp pointy things
sticking out at you that as you're being
thrown around you don't want to hurt
your head and of course you also have uh
the dust
goggles uh because the tanks are
throwing a lot of dust up at you you
don't have a windshield if you're doing
40 m hour there's still enough wind that
you'll notice so you wear a set of
goggles as
well it's good to see armor actually
work so what has happened there is round
hit explosive reactive armor so those
bricks that you see what they generally
consist of though this is a gross
oversimplification is a couple of pieces
of metal sandwiching a piece of
explosive that when a round hits it it
explodes and disrupt or destabilize it
to the extent that the main armor belt
behind can stop
it
from you got a couple of problems
firstly if the entire turret system is
offline then the tank is Still rocking a
little bit it may not look at much but
it's going to be rocking enough that you
cannot hip shoot a 125 on a on a point
target like a tank like that secondly he
he literally is hip shooting he's
eyeballing it I don't see why he
couldn't still be using his Gun Site he
can then pull the trigger
himself sand storms do happen in the
2003 invasion of Iraq there was one that
basically shut down the war for a couple
of days
your big problem with a sandstorm is the
air filters so the sand is going to get
into your air filters and Clogg them up
very quickly however in this context I
don't think they had a heck of a lot of
choice because being chased by platona
m60sbs any
reasonable military context that this
vehicle could exist in the US Army has
vehicle the
m117 uh which is a derivative of the old
lav 100s from Vietnam it's basically a
huge armored 4x4 with a gun turret on
the top uh for military police use I'm
sure they wouldn't mind something like
this so generally speaking convoys just
because of the nature of Roads you tend
to be in column instead of line of
breast like in the shot here you have a
bit of a choice depending on how many
vehicles you have is how far apart you
want the vehicles to be because the idea
is that your lead vehicle is going to be
sufficiently far in front of whatever it
is that you're protecting the main body
of the Convoy so with only three
vehicles you're kind of limited as to
what you can do but your typical it's
going to be maybe two up front then the
main asset and then one bringing you up
the rear
cannons are not common but they are a
thing you can sometimes find them
mounted as experiments on tanks as well
but they're they're basically a waste of
space and weight so you don't see them
on
tanks in terms of the missile
launcher yeah missile launchers on
armored cars are a thing this particular
elevating out of the 4x4 is proba bit
closer to a brdm anti-tank system but
that's actually for anti- armor purposes
not anti-aircraft but hey I guess when
you're dealing with Batman anything goes
I I got nothing zero sorry no she's
fired T
destroyed the Germans appear to be
equipped with pack 40s it was a very
good anti-tank gun 7.5 CM caliber
definitely a valid threat against an
M4
H Traverse left that was a doctrinal
fire command now the reason I know this
is they actually sent me the script
before filming but that is basically
alert Target and uh command of execution
an abbreviated fire command the fire
commands back in World War II weren't
quite as regimented as they are today
but the fundamentals are actually still
the
same you have an argument do you want to
advance over open ground as a whole
platoon or do you want to Bound in
sections in this case because of the am
infantry that they're trying to provide
cover for I can see perhaps why they
went as a full platoon online but also
it's a very very open long field so
maybe it was necessary for the entire
platoon to advance online simply so that
they could see the
target there's another gun who's got
eyes on
it somebody's going to ask how can a
pack 40 Miss at such short range you
will be surprised what stress is going
to do to you so there there have been
studies and the reputation of the 88 is
such that it doesn't miss in reality
they're firing 20 rounds to get a single
kill because the stress of combat is
such that it is not calm and collected
on a guny range when you doing
scientific testing it's oh God I'm about
to die let's light him up let's go let's
clean it
up now that scene is basically why I
became a tanker a line of Tanks every
machine gun going a single tank is
considered to have Firepower more or
less equivalent to an infantry platoon
because you have the heavy machine gun
up top you got a coax machine gun you
got a bow machine gun and oh by the way
you've got a cannon that is a lot of
Firepower from a single vehicle and you
can imagine the sheer suppression and
psychological effect that comes of this
let alone the lethal effects I know
there were folks that didn't like that I
gave the last Fury a nine but I'm giving
this one a nine as
well can't get elevation we know it so
this was an actual problem in
Afghanistan and it's a mountainous
country is that their tanks which were
designed really for open Warfare on the
PLS of Germany can't Elevate High Enough
so what the Soviets ended up doing was
they developed a variant of the zsu 234
anti-aircraft gun the shilka called the
the Afghan so they would use those in
conjunction with the tanks to provide
that close range high elevation security
that dusal here is having a problem
[Music]
with the actual effect of hitting the
gun tube is not going to be the pedling
like you see here that's for visual
effect well you're actually going to get
it's a very small hole uh that goes
through the gun tube but it's still
plenty bad enough that you you've
disabled a
gun the grenade will not have separated
the tracks so I must conclude it was the
Rocks but it's not impossible for Rocky
terrain and maybe a less experienced
driver to angle his track in such a way
when he's turning that he gets rocks
Caught In Between the Wheels and the
tracks and snaps a track pin and that
throws your track and loses it this
scene is probably a seven to an eight my
name is Nicholas Irving I'm a former US
Army Ranger Special Operation Sniper I'm
also known as the reaper for my 33
confirmed kills in
Afghanistan I may have a shot absolutely
not and she's off hand like there's no
support it's all musling it in to uh
make that shot and that gun well yeah
that's no the Olympic
Arms
k23b is what it is that weapon is like
literally accurate for you know up to
like 50 m that distance looks like it's
about at most a couple of hundred yards
put it back in the case and go back and
get a different
one it's not clean for I do not have a
clean shot yeah I don't think she had a
clean shot at all in the military a
clean shot would be um you're not going
to wound or injure or kill something you
don't intend to if her Target is one of
those two men that bullet you know it's
a 556 it's going to zip right through
the bad guy and potentially wound or
kill the guy she's trying to to help out
or save I said take the shot I can't I
may here going take the bloody
shot if I was forced to take the shot I
I'll pull the trigger but I'm not going
to guarantee you anything luckily the
train does kind of like come towards her
as opposed to moving left or right that
takes out so much more of the
mathematics behind making a shot when
it's moving closer or away from you it's
all about just aiming above the Target
or a little bit below the target as
opposed to you know aiming in front of
it and having that individual
essentially run into the bullet I would
rate it a one like it's just not
happening happening at
all that little good tactical deep
breath pause you know before the shot
was really good to be more precise you
essentially have to be calm and one of
the easiest ways to calm your body down
or right before a shot is to just take
deep breaths and get the blood
circulating I would have got more Square
behind the the rifle as opposed to like
having my legs off to the side like that
maybe got down like in a squatting
stance or on my knees and kind of put my
weight behind the gun that way when it
recoils it's kind of more of a straight
back motion and not this motion he's
going to pretty much get that just
because his body alignment and the way
he's holding the
rifle there you
go yeah I think think it was smart for
him to let the vehicle get closer to him
everybody thinks being a sniper we want
the longest furthest shots but ideally
you want the closer ones just because it
makes your job that much easier and it
you know it's almost like 100% guarantee
you're going to hit but with that if I'm
protecting someone and I shoot the
vehicle within you know a few yards from
him the guy is still going to get hit by
the moving
vehicle I don't like that the car just
did a triple axle like 20 ft from the
guy like that's not how that works at
all the only moving vehicles that I've
shot I was a machine gunner and I've
never once made a car flip over normally
they just crash into a wall or crash
into another parked car just roll off
the side of the road into the desert I'd
give it a six the only thing that's
pulling me back I'm giving it a less
lesser number is because of the sniper
waiting for the car to get
[Music]
closer
I mean as far as being a highly accurate
sniper rifle concealed as a flute I
don't think so there's a lot of big
things on on a sniper rifle that makes
it accurate but the barrel is like
really important and most barrels on
sniper rifles are fluted and floated
there's like no interference between the
barrel and the stock of the gun as to
not like interfere with the harmonics
when it goes off that flute looks like
one Contin ly long long object it
probably is accurate maybe at the
distances that he's shooting at but I
also don't know what caliber he's
shooting but it's Tom Cruz so it's
probably really
[Music]
accurate I'd give the female sniper the
best position whatever she's in that
little room or the designs on the walls
I think that really gives her an
advantage it almost it's like shooting
out of a loophole it's like a tactic
snipers used overseas where you punch a
small hole through a wall or something
and a sniper would back away from the
wall and shoot through that hole to hit
an object outside the guy with the
shades on he's not really in a
concealable concealed position but I
guess he's using his attire to make him
least Stand Out worst position I'd have
to say Tom
[Music]
Cruz any sniper rifle can be suppressed
even up to like 50 caliber uh sniper
rifles you're still going to hear like a
noise it sounds like a a clap a loud
clap or if you took a ruler and and
smacked it on a desk unless you use like
subsonic rounds which he may be using in
this instance where I could see nobody
else really hear
anything shooting lights are actually
extremely hard to do like that was one
of our things overseas sometimes when an
assault team is going going up on a
building they want the light shot out
for them to make it dark and that's it's
actually pretty tough cuz it blurs out
everything and it's hard to find exactly
I guess where the middle is at I'll give
it a five those shots are are you know
possible but I don't think that this
scenario setup is that
realistic I grew up watching this movie
it's like one of the reasons why I
wanted to become a sniper every sniper
you have your rifle and you have your
ghilly suit what it essentially does is
break up the outline of the human body
and mimics or makes you appear to be
brush or foilage but it's not just the
ghillie suit that's What Makes You
camouflage what you're going to really
want to do is put a bunch of natural
vegetation into the Gillie suit so you
look more like the natural surrounding
as opposed to just this big pile of of
ghillies suit on the
legs you have the Spotter and you have
the sniper the spotter is the one who's
not pulling the tri trigger and he's
holding up a or using a spotting scope
um through his it looked like a red dot
camera thing or something like that
that's just not what it looks like
either you're going to have a reticle
that mimics are as similar to what the
sniper using these Mill dots or uh
radiant lines that are going to you know
give you your distance and be able to
track with a bullet impacts he's
moving
650 range me
being a sniper it it's like 80 to 90% of
your job is is observation it's actually
really where that a sniper does get a
chance to pull the trigger most of our
stuff is just relaying information
watching stuff taking pictures and
telling the commanders what's going on
on the ground so you can be out there
for as long as the job
needs I think everything he did there
was just fine looks like he's using like
an M24 snip sniper rifle could be or
something similar to that a variant but
um like they're good out to like 800 M
and 650 yards like that's not that's far
but it's not that far for like a sniper
and a body shot which is what I normally
aim for was perfect like that's all
you're going to go for at that distance
my only issue would probably have
something soft underneath his uh his
rifle maybe put down a pack or his
backpack or something you know to to
rest of on that helps with the harmonics
and having the rifle bounce and get all
the way from you I give it a seven I was
going to give it an eight but a seven
because the sniper scope and the
reticles and all that stuff just didn't
make any
sense to stay still when you're pinned
down by a sniper it's like almost a
death wish it's just a matter of time
before he's going to figure something
out to make those bullets impact running
zigzag patterns getting out as fast as
you can is probably your best
bet to prevent an enemy coming in to do
what just happened here sneak up behind
you in Sniper school they teach you no
more than like two shots two or three
shots your sniper hide is burnt um you
would want to move ideally to a new
location once you have a good sniper
hide set up the odds of you like getting
out after that second shot
third shot it's it's it's slim but there
are counter measures to deter people
from entering that sniper hide like for
us we might put up a claymore or some
booby traps or something like that
behind us and even a guy with the
machine gun is usually watching our
back that actually wasn't too bad and
it's at night time with no night vision
so I'll give him that we hit targets at
nighttime um but the distances are
extremely close we had a a sniper scope
that was mounted with a PVS 14 I believe
uh which is a night vision attachment
that goes on the front of your
scope bolt guns bolt rifles they Jam all
the time especially in like Dusty
conditions that bolt gun when you pull
it back it's exposed to the elements and
it's such a slower process proc as
opposed to like a semi-automatic where
the bolt is coming back extremely fast
so it's more prone to collect dust and
things of that nature that would cause
it to to jam up man this is getting
tough I don't know i' give it a six
because realistically shooting at night
time like that I can see you missing
that
much I've debated doing this when I was
pinned down by a sniper in Afghanistan
taking my helmet off if that's your last
resort and all you're trying to do is
locate a sniper's position I would have
probably stuck my helmet up like on a
the tip of my gun and dangled it up as
opposed to like throw it I might need
that for later but there's no way that
enemy sniper would have hit that
though like back in World War II snipers
used to use the trees to hide in and
shoot from and there really is no
benefit to hiding in a tree once they
find you out all they have to do is you
know Center all their guns onto that
tree and chop it down hiding underneath
the tree are like in the the hole of the
tree where some of them get you know
hollowed out I could see that um but I'm
scared of bugs so that's not for
me as far as taking the shot when he
took it nine times out of 10 if a sniper
is being sent out it's to OverWatch his
guys and make sure nothing happens to
them but if we're already engaged and
targets and we're already being shot at
then anything that's moving on that
opposite end that is a threat or has a
weapon is going to get shot so yeah he
had every right to to pop a few rounds
off at this guy I would have too I'd
give it a nine just because I've been in
like a situation where I debated taking
my helmet off and using it as a
decoy
somewhere no so I was an onset
uh Tech advisor on this film and also
played the dead guy that he got the
radio from should have won an award for
it best dead guy ever but that sand was
real um we were really like in the
desert and it was brutal it's extremely
hard to aim through we call it a brown
out where it's just like a a semi little
I guess dust storm that rolls through
you can't see anything so he's
definitely definitely not not going to
be able to make a shot especially at the
distances that he's going for with that
much dust blowing around of screwing uh
his vision give me
back right um I'm not going to say it's
impossible to to take out an enemy
sniper who's hiding among stuff like
that the hardest thing the good sniper
is going to have to do is locate them
from what I remember I recall it being
over a th000 met away which is extremely
EX extremely far to be conducting a
counter sniper
operation the sound of the rifle that
John Cena is firing in the movie is not
how it sounds in real life like this
sounds like a semi-automatic rifle with
like a suppressor on it or something
like that in real life that gun is just
a big thunderous boom a big bang the way
he was shooting in the movie it it's
kind of like I like it's a
semi-automatic as opposed to him
cranking the bolt back every time and
the sound is
off please tell me you got yeah he was
dead from the get-go like shooting in an
open area um and a sniper has eyes on
you it's there's really nothing you can
do about it unless you are going to get
up and just take a chance and run for it
just crawling away slowly wouldn't work
he's just going to watch you crawl and
decide when to shoot anyway so it's it's
illusive lose this scene here I don't
think I worked that day so no I only
have so much control but this scene I
would rate like a oh my I'm doing this
to myself I'm going to give it a
five I don't know if I would be
comfortable with taking that shot
through the the windshield portion of a
helicopter bullets act funny when they
hit objects and the first object that
bullet is going to hit is that glass and
because it's curved it's going to
deflect the bullet up or down left or
right there's really no you know
determining Factor on as to where that
bullet's going to land at so one shot
one kill for that helicopter scene not
so
much from underneath the car that's
actually a good thing to do I've shot
from underneath various vehicles and
structures and stuff like that
especially like in an urban environment
you're going to encounter so much to and
Rubble on the battlefield or where
you're fighting from so you have to make
do with what you have the only issue was
like her hand placement on the rifle
like she already has the bipods I don't
see a need to have her hand underneath
it supporting it as well it's just extra
weight dangling for no reason I would
have probably had my uh support hand
closer or holding the buttstock into my
shoulder pocket as opposed to
that
during sniper school we were always told
to call in an air strike went up against
another sniper cuz it's really tough to
uh you know take out or fight against I
believe she's shooting like a 762 Cali
around which is well within the the
capabilities of taking out a Target at
that distance the odds of it being dead
on at whatever range he was would have
meant that she would have had to know
that distance ahead of time and kind of
uh dial in her scope for that instead
she just stuck it on there and pulled
the trigger on the head it's not really
like that but other than that she I
think she did pretty good given the
circumstances I would have probably done
the same thing but I'd give it an eight
she looked really calm behind it and
some of the best snipers I know are
female yeah so this movie is based off
of an actual sniper uh Miss pavlenko she
was credited with over 309 kills and as
far as putting that bullet through the
tank like that I don't know I've only
aimed at a tank one time and it was by
accident and I was quickly reminded
don't do that again when they pointed
the big cannon my
way she went into her bubble Carlo
Hathcock a Marine Core sniper called it
getting into his bubble that that's what
she's doing when all these mortar shells
and and explosions are going off around
her it's getting into that bubble being
able to shut that outside world off of
the chaos and calming down and ignoring
everything to to pull off a shot I can
relate to that
110% no so bullets don't travel in a
straight line like that they travel at
an arc even at 100 yards so to win that
battle you have to aim higher causing
the bullet to go up and a hit its apex
point and fall back down all snipers are
just like really good NFL quarterbacks
he's throwing it up and they're falling
into the Target and bullets work the
same exact way because it was based on a
true story I'll give it a nine not a 10
just because the bullet trajectory
females women make the best snipers out
there no shot abandoned selective Target
all targs are now free the distances
he's shooting from like that's very
plausible here it looks like he's maybe
at most 150 100 yards away like less
than that cuz he's shooting down so less
than 50 yards possibly the scope is not
bad either I'm used to like m dot Scopes
and Horus reticles and they look like
busy Christmas trees some you know like
without the lights on inside of snipers
Scopes it was a very simple
reticle shooting in a crowded
environment is extremely tough during
the international sniper competition
that I attended that was one of the
challenges was to shoot moving targets
amongst a crowd it's extremely hard to
do but our distances were way further
than what he appears to be shooting by
like a lot at the angles he was you know
he was given and the distances it's not
that complicated just worrying about
where the bullet's going to hit after
you hit your target would be like my
only concern because they're in so close
proximity to each other has a
possibility of getting hit too I would
give it a solid eight uh it's highly
realistic the Scopes are always messed
up I don't I don't understand why they
just don't put a real scope reticle in
there so this is a actual spotting scope
similar to what the individual the the
sniper using in the movie and he's using
it pretty correctly like he's using it
for Target detection to identify where a
threat may be he noticed a little bullet
on the ledge or that window and then you
know finding things that were out of
place that didn't make sense and
eventually finding where the sniper was
to something you see rare in movies the
actual use of Target detection and how
important it is for a sniper to find the
smallest details and things that are out
of place to find out you know find who
they're looking
for what you want to do is be pushed
back away from the hole and not put the
barrel protruding outside of the hole
gives your position away and alleviates
that whole purpose of why you made that
hole in the first place I'll give it a
seven I love the use of Target detection
but he messed up putting putting the
barrel through the hole hey everyone Jay
Lee here 13-year Navy explosive
ordinance disposal or EOD vet did four
combat deployments three to Afghanistan
and one to East
Africa that thing is apparently the
Cadillac of trolleys can I say 100% that
this wouldn't be entertained no because
it might but what I do know is there are
probably a dozen other ways to attack
this device from inside the bus I mean
something rudimentary is getting a stick
with some film so we can take an x-ray
of the device so we can actually see
what's going on Jack I need you to look
at the
wire har cover he is talking on a radio
and or a phone right next to this thing
it's electronically initiated they don't
know if that energy will cause that
device to fire or not so that whole
thing is not realistic
whatsoever
I can't bypass it'll fire it's a
collapsable circuit yeah collapsing
circuits are real it's you know there's
two or more detonators and when you cut
one the other one will fire it's common
for us to train to that it's very uh
unlikely to encounter that in well at
least in Afghanistan in my experience we
didn't encounter a lot of collapsing
circuits as mainly pressure plates stuff
like that very simple circuits Howard
pain Atlanta PD bomb squad Jack I want
you to get out of there and sit tight
we're going to go after the source know
they they should 100% do something to
this device and not just solely rely on
the bomber helping them out there are
tools we have to disrupt um an IED and a
component so it'll disrupt the firing
train it'll disrupt all the circuitry um
and separate components remotely and
then we'll go down check the disruption
and then separate components further and
do our thing Jack I I believe he is a
bomb disposal officer with that the LAPD
he should know these component
recognition uh things and how and and be
able to identify how this device works
or at least have a good idea of it this
definitely gets to zero because he knows
better and he should have taken an
action he should have brought a tool
down there with him he could have taped
it right next to it and disrupted that
thing right off the bus we got under 3
minutes left what do I do first the
pressure sensors I activated when I sat
down if I get up my car explodes this is
uh already hokey because he sat down and
now it's now it's armed and there's a
timer in movies and TV they often
incorporate these big timers where it's
counting down to the detonation but in
all reality it's
mainly a safe and arm type mechanism if
I'm a bomb imp Placer I need to be able
to implace it and then safely get away
so there's a time but you're not going
to see you're not going to see this
giant clock it's like you have 5 minutes
before you die orange yellow green
colors don't matter when I need need to
do is tell me which one is hot to the
touch the warm wire versus cold wires
you can make a circuit with the proper
resistance so none of the wires are warm
so like the movie tropes of the warm
wire and or the colors of the wires is a
total farce I can go to Home Depot
Lowe's whichever hardware store your
your your your Hardware sort of choice
get any color wire I want right and put
it in here take small box out of the kit
and turn it
on that kit probably looked like
something I would pull tools from in a
soft Special Operations forces
environment from my experience in
Afghanistan I it was all Special
Operations forces or Naval special
Warfare we flew in helicopters somewhere
landed and ran to a Target right or
walked a great distance to get to a
Target you really want to limit what you
have on your body so yeah we're not
going to be carrying around briefcases
and backpack just full of
tools just cut it in the middle the
orange wire between the two
clamps I don't want to get into that
specifically in detail because that uh
is how we attack some certain things but
yeah those clamps are very they're for a
very specific purpose for multiple
detonators and you would need another
item that he doesn't have there to to do
diagnostics uh diagnostic work on that
type of device you would need a little
bit more time I mean a lot more training
than just him saying oh yeah clamp it on
the warm wire and then cut in between it
right there's a lot of testing you have
to do before you can cut a wire but yeah
the whole setting him sitting down in it
arming it and then like having this
opportunity to render it safe yeah you
wish so yeah we'll give them a two we'll
give them a
two how it was set up and how it was in
place totally legit he had a claymore he
put it on top of the Grand Slam bomb
huge British bomb Claymores are used all
over they're already wired they're pre
they're pre-made to to be set up as
booby traps that's what they're for um
so he just had the trip wire put um
something that he thought one of these
people chasing him idiots would
grab there are 100% bomb detection dogs
and in this clip those dogs I believe
are going for uh human detection they're
going for uh sniffing out Rambo not
necessarily sniff out explosive hazards
in the woods and even if they were those
dogs are running full speed that's like
essentially you trying to sniff a hot
dog in the corner while sprinting down
the hallway like hyperventilating
essentially it's never going to
happen would the blast wave be that
extended I mean it was drawn out um to
have that effect the explosive component
in there is torpex they added aluminum
into the the composition of that
explosive to extend the blast but with
that being said that's like a nuclear
blast wave that is just like kind of
continuing to go out it would be really
big and and
done that blast wave would have killed a
lesser man not John Ram
the explosive component in there is
torpex it's about 50% stronger than TNT
and that's only the blast frag goes
exponentially further than blast does so
yeah he is definitely within that this
is probably the most realistic clip as
far as how things function and how
people think man I'm going have to I
might give Rambo an eight he's kned two
because of survival that's hokey at best
even for John Rambo I got it uh it's a
cylinder Cipher d u n a n it's my last
name it knows who I am if someone is
just going to make an improvised nuclear
device like this Cipher anything is
possible there's many ways that uh
nuclear weapons are armed you can't get
into any specifics there're state
sponsored and then there's non-state
sponsored State sponsor going to have
all kinds of different protocols in
place safeties what have you arming
sequences non-state sponsored if if
someone is just going to make an
improvised nuclear device like this
Cipher it can be armed when it hears
your voice when my voice whatever the
case may be I speak without a mouth I
fly through the air without wings what
am I an echo that's it that's it that's
I can't I I can't even with this one
this is this is he's talking to it how
does he know if he answers this question
it's not going to go
off it's empty apparently it was a mud
suck right a hoax ID um or a hoax device
real life hoaxes are actually very
common very common especially in Iraq
and Afghanistan um they were utilized as
intelligence gathering devices
essentially they' put it in the road
totally fake just something that would
key up EOD response an EOD response and
then they would be watching and
videotaping the whole procedure despite
all of the craziness that was in the
scene using a hoax to gather
intelligence on people and to learn more
about them absolutely true we'll give
this one a eight up there with
Rambo oh God we would clown this movie
so much in training like we would just
pretend we're this dude and just do the
most outlandish because that's exactly
what he did uh he's attacking a vbid uh
which is a vehicle born improvised
explosive device walking up to a vbid
without a tool an explosive tool an
energetic tool or anything not even a
pole line or anything to prosecute this
this vehicle is just dumb he went down
range in a bomb suit with a crowbar I
mean cool they would probably send a
robot down with a tool first right
especially because yeah that's a lot of
H A vbit is no joke there's a I mean
even the even the guys on the wall his
security element they'd probably die if
that thing went
off the hell is he
doing
dead dead he could have died a half
dozen to a dozen ways in this in this
clip alone not to mention the whole
movie kicking it randomly opening the
opening the trunk by hand opening the
hood by hand turning the windshield
wipers on yanking random wires
underneath the hood like any one of
those could have set that thing off yeah
I think he removed his headset please
put your headset back
on the most realistic thing in there was
the was the radio thing he actually took
his headset off so he could focus and
and and get his thought process going
and then when they asked him to put it
back on yeah that's probably the
response that You' get from from an EOD
Tech we definitely render safe iids by
hand I've done it um and it's not ideal
we want to go as remote as possible
because of the risk of something going
off but yeah he could have done a lot
more with his hands like cut de cord um
detonating cord right out right at the
gate I forgot how many were how many
155s but that that's what was in the
trunk of that car once he saw the the
main charge and that's what he should be
going after anyway just Reckless abandon
yeah this is just it's totally Hollywood
it up the only realistic thing was the
communication aspect of it he gets a one
one out of
[Music]
10 3 miles underwater the water's
crystal clear so I mean
that's no there's no way my fourth team
I was on a mine counter measure team but
it was underwater seam mines and
underwater IEDs and stuff like that this
is supposed to be a nuke that has fallen
into the abyss it's a big deal when we
go to 200 ft of seawater we're
definitely not going to do free Ascent
to the bottom there's always descent
lines we we establish a safe area yeah
he doesn't have any search tools
whatsoever he just has his eyeballs and
a flare which is insane and that's just
the diving aspect so we haven't even
gotten to the EOD part of
it we made it we'll go step by step the
communication is totally woo it's 3
miles underwater what RF signal can
reach can penetrate three miles worth of
of water we do have very rudimentary
ways of communicating I.E a float on the
top of the water that's connected to us
via a line and we'll just pull it and
the certain number of of poles means a
certain thing so we communicate like
that in a bottom line Centric
environment where we're taking seismic
and magnetic precautions but yeah nuke
that is a totally different ball game
you have to cut the ground wire not the
lead
wire without getting into any super
specifics on nuclear weapons design we
would have researched this ordinance
item this is exactly how you render it
safe if we want to separate components
separate the fuse from it sometimes we
do that explosively sometimes we do it
mechanically and then we just raise it
up and bring it to the beach and exploit
it on the surface I'd have to give that
a big fat Donut for realism a zero
because that's not at all how nuclear
weapons
function te McIntyre can you hear me I
love this show it's so funny unexploded
ordinance uxo um those are very common
because sometimes fuse is just dut out
and it's still a threat because we just
don't know the condition of it right why
did it not go off is it a time is it a
proximity thing is it a is it a delay
that just hasn't gone all the way yet so
very much a concern let's hope for
everyone else that's behind cover but
mainly for the guys that are right on
top of it heartbeats
regular you spring a leak stop taking it
is definitely plausible to use a
stethoscope to examine a suspected
Clockwork fuse seems hokey but yeah that
is old school legit it was a thing for
old bombs like that they had Clockwork
mechanisms in the fuse that you could
hear ticking down we don't see that a
lot anymore that was a lot of training
in school um just to get the exposure to
it there a propaganda bom leaflets are
definitely employed they were dropped in
all over um Europe during World War II
they were employed in I mean North Korea
Vietnam leaflets are definitely a type
of psychological warfare or even just a
means to communicate with uh a
population that just
is confined to an area but I give it a
solid seven for realism granted two
random people would not be working on
this on this bomb but yes so we got a it
a little bit I just don't know why they
didn't have any bomb squad people so on
the side of the timer there should be a
serial number that'll tell me which wire
y'all need to cut Archer here is showing
an inexperienced person being coached
through this whole ordeal like many
other movies and TV shows it would be
almost impossible um unless it was set
up exactly how the manufacturer wanted
it to be set up if that's the case
totally doable right I can walk you
through anything it's like okay cool how
many wires are there what colors are
they you ready damn it letter is B Bravo
thanks second letter is m is in Mike oh
my God that is so spoton as far as
Communications especially when hitting
the fan H I can relate you have radio
frequencies you have interference you
have distance you have other things in
the way so your signal can be degraded
everyone is getting ramped up in this
episode but in real life when stuff is
going on and comms are an an issue
you just really stay calm and cool and
Collective on the radio that way even if
it is weak a weak signal you can still
hear what's being said I'm doing it God
oh my God R what's going on the timer
sped up the Trope here with the green
wire being cut and speeding up the clock
is just erroneous it makes no sense to
have that feature in there unless you're
trying to create some type of anxiety
and in real life trust me if you're
faced with it live explosive that can
detonate at any action keeping that at
Bay is already going to be uh difficult
enough so yeah at the end of the day
people want their things to go off so
that's how they make them I'll give them
a four the communication piece that was
hilariously accurate bombs aren on the
same fire line I have to diffuse them
individually how long is it going to
take I got to find them and then
dismantle them 30 minutes there's just
like a chunk of high explosive taped to
a pipe e would see that and boom and
make a call and everyone would get out
of there except for one other person him
and one other security person and then
I'm going to take immediate action on
that device um and immediate is
immediate it's not 30
minutes he was using a mirror for
whatever reason I'm not going to use a a
a an inspection mirror when I have my
eyeballs and I can see all the way
around it so yeah that's kind of hokey
he's got nods on his helmet so that's um
cumbersome especially when he's working
on that one that was at head level his
nods could hit it and if there's an
anti- move thing on there boom he just
functioned it as designed so I would
take my helmet off so there's nothing um
no obstructions that could potentially
hit this
device if he's the only one there yeah
that's what he's got to do because it's
threat assessment of what's going to
kill me right now that's an enemy
combatant he's probably going to kill me
if he sees me so that needs to be taken
care of first but yeah he would have at
least one shooter with him a little bit
of ways so when I'm working um I can be
focused on this they could have classed
it up a little bit but all
good Bingo he did use ceramic scissors
at the end I thought that was a nice
touch granted he used ceramic scissors
instead of diagonal cutters and
typically when wires are coiled up like
that there's two of them and he cut them
both he could have smooshed the two
wires that are conductive together
and set it off yeah there's a lot of
hokey stuff so yeah it's got to be low
low
three the general direction of the
mountain the robot really finds what
you're looking for they're in Helman
which I was also in Helman uh Helman
provin in Afghanistan and yeah robots
are awesome I didn't see the robot go
down with a tool tool in tool out that's
what we do that's what's preached from
day one in EOD School the robot has
Cutters on it it has grippers and
separate components whatever the case
may be so if it did find something it
could countercharge it or they could set
it
down
no at the end of the day that is what a
robot is for they are expendable devices
if worst comes to worse they find
something by functioning it it blows up
Not a Human Being the entire team was
was standing out in front of the
vehicles that's totally not what would
happen they would be inside their
vehicle driving this robot that way you
have um mitigation from fragmentation
coming at you at least be behind the
vehicle for God's sake I need you to
keep your
head
still don't
nod this is a close pin switch very old
very
rudimentary very easy to defeat Nick the
EOD operator should seeing that he
identified that it's a pull cool cut it
right just cut it and be done with it
but he did the thing of holding his head
you tell someone that they're connected
to a line with a bunch of explosives
they're going to freak out that's one of
the one of the rare times where you you
can actually attack a switch it's a very
clearcut we
need that could have been handled way
differently and then everyone would have
survived it's tough you know a lot of a
lot of EOD procedures and tactics are
Written in Blood just like this the
survivors like okay this is exactly what
they encountered over the radio this is
what was said now we have our new set of
ttps so it doesn't happen again I'll be
this one to five it's got some stuff
some super hokey stuff but uh all in all
not bad what are you doing I can get it
out over the
B the plausibility of having a bomb that
is unable to be rendered safe it's all a
matter of time really if time is you
know not not an object then yeah you can
you can spend the time and the diligence
and really get it disassembled to where
it's you know it's demilled so now you
have to weigh can I render this safe in
a minute and 30 seconds or not and the
answer is probably no right because
especially with a device as
sophisticated as that was supposed to be
your best case is you have a minute 30
to get this as far away from everyone as
possible
yeah water is a great uh has a great
tamping effect because it cannot
compress it really depends on what the
actual explosive the nuclear yield of
this bomb was and how deep it was able
to go the mission of EOD is protection
of personal and property so yeah getting
that device out in way moving it
relocating it even if it's to your own
demise is what what we would do um for
the sake of protecting personnel and
property is it a nine can Batman be a
nine I'll give it a nine I like to think
his actions were genuine of Navy EOD hey
my name is dakata Brody I'm a 21-year
military veteran I served 13 years in
the US Coast Guard as a search and
rescue helicopter pilot and 8 years in
the Army as a uh60 Blackhawk helicopter
pilot all right tuck them in boys for
the the Coast Guard primarily we Face
offshore and going offshore is to affect
most of our rescues however the Coast
Guard does train for uh vertical surface
rescues which is what you're seeing
right here Cliff side Cliff rescues and
everything else stay perfectly still I
have to stabilize the car okay car
secur all right if that is the Hoist
hook you are in what you call a
committed situation every H pilot would
be shaken at this point right now
knowing that the Hoist Hook is attached
to a vehicle that can fall off not
happening we're not connecting up to any
vehicle Joy I'm coming down Harrison
you're
flying so a pilot going to the back seat
first of all you know how much stuff you
can knock off you could literally turn
off both of your engines the fact that
your vest and everything could snag and
you could flip things off we've actually
had a person turn with their mvgs
sitting on top of their head and
actually hit hit one of the engines and
knock an engine offline with that so
yeah it's very possible to actually turn
off something inadvertently just
climbing trying to get to the back of
the cabin out the
door sadly don't you worry I'm going to
get you out it if I am outside the
helicopter we have a real bad problem as
a pilot I am never
outside I got you got it show me
[Music]
swing
they were trying to show like the Hoist
was holding the truck up right the Hoist
that you have on there about 600 lb so
it's not your primary means of holding
up anything at that point that it was
smoking it was straining so hard now
there is a squib that you could flip the
switch to actually cut and Shear that
hoist cable which is what they were
doing at that point so somehow they
sheared the one cable and The Rock and
the other person was on a different
cable I don't know what that is I'll say
that our helicopter has one cable that
we're going to operate with once that
cable gets sheared everything is going
down with it it's not going to happen on
so many different levels on this clip
this right here is a zero where are they
tankers on the way Ace 2 1 I don't know
why nobody wears mvgs everybody has mvgs
on night vision goggles on at the
helicopters nobody wears them if you
have the option of having them on yeah
you're going to have them
on
the fuel probe that you just saw that's
not a standard piece of equipment on
helicopters there just certain
helicopters that are either doing some
long range rescues most helicopters do
not have
that your biggest thing at that point is
if you miss where's that tube that's
going that's flowing fuel if you're
going to cut that thing with the main
rotor you're talking about damage to the
main main rotor system you'd be in a bad
spot at that
point looking right now at a lightning
strike knock on wood and thank God I've
never had that happen you risk frying a
lot of electronics engine control
systems that are on there you're hoping
that your engines are staying online you
would probably lose a lot of electronic
AC and DC Systems inside the helicopter
but you should be able to keep flying
unless you got hit in like the tail
rotor or
something every year the Coast Guard has
to do what's called dunker training so
we get flipped over in a chair in a pool
which simulates having to ditch you're
rolled upside down you have to do
multiple different egresses to show that
you have the proficiency to be able to
get out of a submerged helicopter every
single year and then every six years if
unless they've changed it but every six
years you go to actual school where you
go through the whole mockup simulator of
a device going in and rolling over so
this is a part of the
business he's got seiz bottle or heed
bottle which gives you about 2 to three
minutes at normal breath in that mode
right there you have about 10 to 15
seconds if they're breathing the way I
think they are but the pure shock of
going in and the water temperature
itself is going to take that breath out
of you but I do like the realistic
aspect of seeing somebody grab that seiz
bot and put that thing in their
Mouse now for everybody that flies we
have emergency jettison handles so the
normal exits are no longer going to get
you out of the door it's too much
pressure that's on that door at that
point so you're literally hitting your
emergency jettison like it's blowing
cartridg and the door pops off it just
is lifting up the actual door hinge pins
out of the way so you can have a create
that full opening at that point
anybody's going for that yeah you're
going to die I give this one probably
about a six you can lower me down I'll
get the two men you return and pick us
up on my signal the theatrics on there
is amazing they had no business being
that close to a rig that's exploding so
we've done multiple rescues in the Gulf
of Mexico that's where I was stationed
at before so flying out to rigs rigs
typically have burn-offs happening but
there's always either gases or stuff
like that that's coming off so the rigs
all have more of a Escape type pods and
things for the rig work to be able to
get out and be able to get off the rigs
and then we would affect the rescue from
the Open Water to try to go into there
again we're no good to anybody and it's
so much risk of that flying debris
shrapnel going through the rotor blade
system you're just now a victim you're
not going to put yourself or the crew in
that situation
down any standard deployment of the
rescue swimmer they're just going going
down at that point you just call it a
direct deployment of the rescue swimmer
especially when you're deploying
somebody either to a boat that's
underway you'll have them down you'll
have them just off the water or just
above but to say that you about to send
somebody through a flame blowtorch in
essence not going to
[Music]
happen when somebody is on the cable the
hook is actually locked just to prevent
any mishap to where it could
inadvertently come open for somebody to
pette and unhook themselves off the
cable at the same time that's pretty
amazing nobody would be that crazy to
even attempt to put somebody in that
situation the rescue swimmer would come
up and slap everybody in that helicopter
for even putting them down and Stu like
that so absolutely not it's completely
unrealistic that's a
zero R Us
away when he jumps from the helicopter
that's a free fall deployment of the
rescue swimmer that is reserved for
daytime only so we would have only
hoisted the rescue swimmer down at that
point not let him jump from the
helicopter if they're seeing like 20
foot swells or something like that that
means the helicopter is hovering at
least 30 to 40 ft you misjudge that
swell that's a four or five story drop
that water turn into a solid real quick
especially if those cold
temperatures I have pick signal bask is
going out
the bask in the it's a standard rescue
basket he's calling for the basket has
the ready for pickup sign that's exactly
what you would hear cuz we're standing
by keeping our light in the direction of
the swimmer kind of making sure we
always have sight on them and as they're
getting ready you're going to try to
place the device really within about 5
to 10 feet of them once they're calling
for it so very very real we look fueling
Bingo out of we got go that Bingo fuel
that's a real term it just means like if
you leave now you will land with a fuel
Reserve when you get back at your
station anything that's less than there
you can be at risk of either not making
it to your destination or airport or
flaming out it's always a race against
how much fuel you
have behind you
when you're seeing the winds that rotor
wash it's beating down on you it's a
mini hurricane underneath it there's no
communicating with the swimmer in the
water at that point in time all hand arm
signals that would be insane to think
that you're going to hear a person a
swimmer in the water underneath a
spinning helicopter not going to happen
on
there the waves out there that's in like
the Arctic kind of where I believe that
scene was taking place 20 30 foot seas
and even having rogue waves can happen
but you try to be above that the
explosion that's the Hollywood part I've
seen helicopters crash on tarmac and
different things and I haven't seen one
explode even in the Army I saw one take
a S7 and hit the engine out that was the
only one I saw that was on fire I'll
give it a seven it's a CO guard it must
have picked up to theet call swimmer's
ready deploy
swimmer
so far right now you're seeing pretty
much a legitimate helicopter rescue it's
daytime you can freef fall the swimmer
in daytime their altitude was good where
the swimmer could safely go out the
swimmer is going to have their goggles
everything down they're not going to
freef fall with their gear up they go in
the water they're going to lose all
their gear so they're going down they're
going to cover their mask and everything
as they going
[Music]
in the device going down and being
placed about 5T from them in the water
that's just text book Coast Guard rescue
swimmer operations on
there when you have Baywatch that's
really the LA County's fire department
they're AKA Baywatch here in the Los
Angeles area we hoist with them
routinely the rescue Sumer could easily
just bring them over to the vessel the
fire department they're trained
paramedics as well primarily you're
going to try to put people in with the
least risky rescue method which would be
to put them on the boat unless they had
sustained something else that they
needed immediate transport bring him
into the helicopter and transport him to
the nearest hospital but the rescue in
itself that's pretty textbook for what
you could see if you're going to freef
fall the rescue swimmer yes it's a nine
just because of how the rescue swimmer
had his goggles and stuff on top of his
head I love the Precision flying of that
this is the MH 68 or W 109 The Sting
race really what you'll call for hitron
which is our helicopters tactics
interdiction it's a specialized unit
that that we have that primarily their
focus is interdicting either drug
smugglers or anything else like that in
international waters mostly dealing with
drug smuggling what you'll call it go
fast you'll typically outrun a boat your
normal cruise is somewhere around like
the 120 to 130 130 knots if you're
really got like a good tailwind and
stuff like
that watch out he got a weapon on board
H out
out I've never been at hitron I did fly
uh Airborne use of force with the Coast
Guard a lot of times what you're trying
to do is we're going to try to stay
outside of what they have on the on
board of there and make sure we can at
least maximize the use of our weapon
systems take
down they went for the kill shots right
there so normally they're going to
probably put some stitches in in the
water they say stitches in the water cuz
when you see it it looks like stitches
from the machine gun being gone out
that's kind of just to escalate the
level of the use of force at that point
before they try to shoot the engines out
and really are more so trying to just
disable the vessel that's primarily what
they're doing at is disabling The Vessel
so I give them about a
seven at any point in time you're
committed you have something that's
attached to something that can pull you
down that's just the worst situation for
a helicopter right so you're just at the
mercy of being on that pivot point and
just completely
helpless wet slippery hand conditions
trying to hold on to a ladder with
adrenaline and the amount of rotor wash
it's a mini hurricane down there so
you're holding on with quite a bit of
grip so I'm pretty sure you're almost
probably bare hugging the ladder at any
point just to try to maintain your grip
we're going to stop cut it now we going
to die here I said it they were actually
doing well talking as a crew for saying
get rid of it that's a tough call it
sounds easy do watch the movie and say
that but that is a really hard call to
say sheer even we're getting ready to
start any hoist and rescues like hey if
this happens you'll say Shear three
times safety po or the flight Mech you
race for that Shear button it was a
eight for how Dynamic that environment
would
[Music]
be the stretcher we call it a litter
anytime we're going to use a litter
we're going to use a trail line to help
stabilize cuz that flat plane surface
that's underneath with all the rotor
wash that's down below will really have
a good propensity to have somebody start
spinning really
quick I'm not sure what was causing the
pilot to struggle so much he's got the
whole ship to look at as far as in
reference power really wasn't an issue
it almost looked like they were making
the Hoist cable feel like it was somehow
taking power away from the engines I
don't
know having a fouled cable or watching
the cable actually bird cage that part
is real that can happen so it could go
go in there and not be you can let out
some more cable at that
point I don't understand why the pilot
was struggling so bad I'm not sure at
this point what's got a hold of them is
some good bait that's clearly under
there for whatever is eatting on them so
there's no need to take the whole
helicopter down Shear Shear Shear well
to preserve the lives of the rest of the
crew there's nothing else you you could
do this is more of of a
three please don't shoot the flare at
the helicopter we see the flare in the
distance trust us the flare gets on the
raft it'll start eating through it's
like a phosphor material so you're
shooting like hot phosphorus at the
thing that's trying to rescue you you're
trying to take us down with you at that
point in time the flare is meant to be
seen not to be caught we just want to
see the flare go up and then find the
point of origin so we could come and
affect the rest
use a lot of times if we're going out
it's more than likely just one
helicopter not saying you can't have two
if it's a Longshore rescue as well
there's a fixed Wing asset overhead that
will probably go out and do really good
radar sweeps inside of the area and try
to help us and they'll also be able to
drop and deliver any type of rescue
materials certain helicopters do have
radar systems so we're trying to either
see a blip on the radar or we're trying
to map the shoreline when we're out
there in really poor weather
conditions helicopters have a few
different lights so each pilot have
their own search light and then a lot of
times they'll operate with What's called
the night Sun so it's just a really
powerful search light toward is the
middle or the back of the cabin this
right here is probably a 9.5 hi I'm John
Spencer I'm the chair of urban Warfare
studies at the Modern War insute I spent
over 25 years in the US Army but I've
been studying Urban Warfare for over a
decade it's very accurate to be behind a
wall when you pop out for a second to
throw a grenade like that where he's
throwing the grenade is a little off
grenades have a timer in them basically
so they don't blow up in your hand once
it hits the target do not throw
explode 100% air support is that that
vulnerable in urban operations and why
usually you don't bring it in it's low
flying it's slow it doesn't have much
protection and usually drop soldiers
offset of the urban battle in this
situation they didn't expect that level
of
resistance crossing the street can
actually be one of the most vulnerable
things of urban Warfare because there's
so many angles so many windows so many
doorways which you can get shot so we
teach things like throwing smoke out
that so that people can't see you and
going one at a time and mixing up the
speed on which you're going if I didn't
know this battle the battle of Mishu I
would say that this is not realistic
where you have hundreds of people
shooting at a small unit but that's
really what happened and they got the
soldiers pretty accurate but there's
been a lot of criticism about this movie
and the depiction of the Somali and kind
of the context of what what's going on
in Mishu at this time hey stay away from
the
walls
okay that's actually an iconic scene
when he says stay off the walls that was
a real advice because once the bullets
are hitting the walls and they travel
down the wall kind of like a bowling
alley and it can hit if you're standing
on that I wouldn't say it happens in all
because every city is different mud
cement glass metal is a little different
but that's
real
[Music]
you see the bullet holes in the glass
because back then we we weren't as
prepared for urban Warfare as we are
today so those aren't bulletproof
Vehicles a lot of the weapons there
aren't really ready for that environment
that they're moving into but they also
were surprised by what they encountered
so I'd give it a like a nine from
realism in urban Warfare not realism in
portrayal of the population and things
are going
on Chris himsworth is more like Jason
Bourne there with his hand toand Close
Quarters fighting is very common to
Urban Warfare we actually tie the
weapons to ourselves so if we're get
caught in that situation and turn a
corner somebody grabs our weapon they
can't take it away from us but not the
tactics that you're seeing in that scene
because he's surrounded by people with
bigger guns um so he's trying to disarm
one while another one's there personally
I would have tried to disarm one of them
with what one of those rifles and then
get your back against something so
you're not expecting a bad guy 360
degrees and then incapacitate them in
some
way I can't say I found myself in a
similar situation or we teach that but
it could work absolutely slow the person
down buy yourself some time I'd say
you'd want to turn Corners as much as
possible especially in a building like
that just to confuse them on which way
you
went out of everything out of that scene
that's probably the most realistic the
fact that he's hiding behind a column
that column is a supporting column so it
has steel reinforced Concrete where some
walls are can be paper thin it could be
plaster if you don't have that then you
do get behind things like furniture and
other things anything you can to try to
get you cover yeah it was a lot of fun
to watch but i' give it about a Wonder
or two and real
ISM I actually love this clip and I wish
I could show show it to more soldiers to
think about buildings differently
especially if you're defending a house
you want to take the stairways away you
want to take the doors away and
absolutely throw furniture down but the
scene is really great too because it
shows you that that's not necessarily
what you stay behind to protect you from
bullets cuz bullets pass through wood
through cloth and
everything that's a great lesson that
clip teaches you that we teach our
soldiers is to stay away from Windows
you crouch down to go underneath them
kind of slowly walk your way around them
bullets incoming probably wouldn't be
that dramatic uh but like that
absolutely we tell you to stay away from
Windows that clip is is really important
to what people don't even think about
even in the military called Mouse ho
holding putting holes and walls and
Floors to move throughout the without
being seen it's very common in major
Urban battles actually I I would love
for soldiers to carry an axe or
something like that but there are other
ways to do it sometimes we use
explosives uh sledgehammers axes like
that to make that whole real tactics
real everything so I'm going with a nine
on that
actually I mean this scene seems very
very familiar to me because I had my own
deployments to Iraq into Baghdad where
we're doing raids like these where
there's only a few terrorist in a
population of Millions for the advantage
of your equipment you can see at night
but also to reduce the risk of being
observed and the risk to civilians the
fact that their their night vision
goggles are always on top of their head
is not realistic you'd want to cut the
power or eliminate the light sources so
you want to use those goggles to your
advantage
it's very common and very smart to have
a sniper with OverWatch who has angles
that the people moving into the house
can't see it's a really good call for
the sniper to be the one to execute the
first shot because you want to save your
surprise to the last moment and the
snipers usually has a silenced weapon
this sniper in particular he'd probably
be wearing more more equipment and
usually it's a sniper and a spotter so
there'd be other people with with
[Music]
him the way they enter this house is a
very common almost too common thing
that's portrayed in movies it's called
enter and clear of room throwing a
grenade can be the preferred tactic if
it's known to be an enemy location and
you know there's somebody in with a
weapon of course you're going to enter
it with something other than your face
so the way they're stack on the door is
about getting in there quickly actually
evolved from SWAT tactics these tactics
were actually developed to limit that
amount of violence because there may be
civilians inter miixed in
there the tactic you see Bradley Cooper
employing there is what I would teach
want to get behind something that's
going to stop the bullets that people
are shooting at you but also be able to
return fire we call that cover the
windows are great uh to get down behind
kneel Behind still shoot from unlike the
enemy in that scene running out into the
open areas that's actually the opposite
of what actually happens they're going
to stay inside the rooms make you come
in there you going get off the streets
and the alleys on the
Move On The Move I'm in
Pursuit when he goes off by himself and
chases that's not realistic we don't
move by ourselves anywhere it's almost
like a cardinal wool so it' be another
team person right there with them and
communicating to each other using some
type of radio or something if he says
moving and then else would follow him
out there I'd give it a rating of around
an
eight
Ambush this happened to me in in Iraq
Ambush initiated by an RPG ambushes are
very very common in urban Warfare It's
meant to surprise the people and trap
them in a a funnel like that although
the bad guys don't usually just stand on
top of the
roof
you would not be standing in the middle
of the street shooting back you wouldn't
last long we'd seek cover use those
armored vehicles which is great ideally
though in the whole situation it's
called a Kill Zone of the Ambush you
want to get out of
it that concept of having a we call it a
quick reaction force a backup team
because you've been surprised somebody
needs to come to help you and we usually
keep forces in their uniform ready to go
in an urban setting like this to be that
quick reaction force to come to that
Aid let go
go they Ram the vehicle which is very
common trying to lock them in that kill
zone so everybody can shoot at you so
I'm actually going to give it a higher
rating than I want to because the Ambush
is so uh real outside the tactics so
I'll give it a let's give it a
four the Drone are probably the most
ubiquitous change to Urban warfare
that's happened in decades as I go into
Ukraine to research Urban Warfare right
now and the major battles there's
thousands and thousands of drones being
used it reduces some of the challenges
of urban Warfare if I can put a drone in
front of the soldier to see around that
corner to see over that building the
aspect of x-ray vision were not there
yet because we still can't see through
concrete especially not much can see
through Steel
it gave me a lot of feelings of of of
real stuff that's happened especially
the use of the dump truck reminds me of
the bayout bombings where a dump truck
was brought to the front of the base
liking that scenario but didn't exploded
this is why Urban Warfare is so hard you
a dump truck could be a
threat although that's probably unlikely
that you're going to use your vibranium
Shield to throw it up in the air but
what it signed for me is that what we
call a three block war where when you're
fighting an Urban Terrain you are
actually very concerned about the
civilian population and protecting
people at the same time as you're
fighting and there's restrictions on
what you can or can't do so no that's a
very plausible scenario that any soldier
who has a has values is trying to
protect the civilian population while
still trying to do it the mission so if
the rating has to be for realism I'll
give it around a
six H 10 Tang goes front left by
the there a couple little things in
there there are nice touches of adding
realism to the situation like the Red
Dot that you see on your scopes on
Modern weapons that will kind of help
you aim to the green Hue that you see on
their eyeballs that coming off the night
vision goggles so when you see some
version of night vision goggles you kind
of Martian type of look when you look
around everybody's got green eyes to the
top of this building let's go we blocked
by buildings we got no vantage point
this Roost is above
in this scene they enter a really strong
building like that it's a great a great
idea the strategy was called strong
points or a building that is really
strong it has lines of sight or or
directions you can fire from in multiple
directions and in war it's happened
where a single building been held for
months just because of the it was the
right strong point he says it's a bus
because depending on what type the
direction of the building where the
enemy is they got up there thought
they'd have good vantage point but they
couldn't anything so it was a
bust take on your
right what we usually see in urban
Warfare movies is everybody trying to
get to the roof because it kind of has
common sense I can shoot down I can see
people farther out but depending on the
context you don't want to be anywhere
near the roof because you can also be
seen from the air from drones from
mortars you can be hit this based on a
real situation that happened in 2012 uh
Benghazi where they're attacking the
embassy compound that's a good idea to
get up there so you can see where
they're coming from and to take better
shots and not waste ammo from the
rooftop for sure I give that a pretty
high rating in realism about a seven
eight just based on the the type of
weapons the tactics the chaos the
building construction it's pretty
real that window I think is an important
scene because one of the biggest miss
that TV and movies show about Urban
Warfare is that it's just infantry or
soldiers shooting their weapons major
Urban battles are tanks artillery
Engineers infantry they're full scale
battles in concrete now the damage that
the tank does to the building that is
unlikely that the just the whole face of
the building is going to fall off it's
going to do a lot of damage and that's
why you have a tank because a tank is
mobile protected Firepower has that that
giant gun that can punch through that
problem which is concrete and cover but
in this scene that they're all tracers
it's almost like a Star Wars ray gun
they won't all be like
[Music]
that there's actually a myth that tanks
are not helpful in urban Weare they're
too vulnerable but actually the history
of urban Warfare if you go into a major
urban fight and you don't have a tank
you're wrong but the problem is that the
tank can't go by itself and the Infantry
can't go by itself and as we see in the
scene the Infantry work to protect the
tank and then the tank protect the
Infantry but tanks are vulnerable as you
see here the Germans shoot from below
where the tank can shoot in the
basement come
here the size needed to take a town or a
village or a city all depends on what
the enemy it is that you're they're
facing and I think they really didn't
know for that street I think that looked
about right absolutely where you combine
a tank section always two tanks with an
infantry platoon or something to to
clear a street like that before you
discover where the enemy is outside of
the lasers of the rounds this is a very
realistic scene of high-intensity combat
um and the combined arms that you need
so I give it a
nine
oh we pause one thing that I I can't
help myself on the scene is that
everyone walks up to the wall and just
sticks their rifle over the top of the
wall that's absolutely what you don't do
you're just putting a flag up the same
where you are I don't have any problem
with them moving to the rooftops um this
is a hasty attack two different
buildings that's great it gives you
converging fire so fire them down from
two different directions they can cover
more of of the courtyards this scene in
this movie is is based on the real
Battle of mul that happened in 2017 one
of the biggest battles really since
World War II 100,000 Security Forces
against a entrenched uh Isis enemy force
that they had to be cleared
out that's actually pretty realistic you
open an attack like that with your
biggest weapon we call it the most
casually producing weapons Duds do
happen the way you usually get around
that is you have more than a single
point of failure more than one big
weapon or like they do here which is
actually accurate is once that does
that's it your surprise is gone
attack it's actually pretty complex what
they're trying to do because they have
moving forces with other elements
shooting down that they have to know and
watch very closely on when to turn their
fire off as you advance that's in some
ways the way I would have teach it to as
well as they're maneuvering in while
another person is holding them
down booby traps are are very popular in
urban Warfare pictures on the wall in
everything could be potentially booby
traps we see it right now in the Ukraine
war when Ukraine takes back their own
house their territories from the
Russians but you have to be hyper aware
of all those booby traps for sure one is
it's awareness of every Soldier not to
move and displace things and then we
have bomb stiffing dogs will'll bring in
I'm going to actually give it around a a
five six just some of it's a little
off he'll be on the foot walk over the
gutter we'll take him out from
behind the underground is a huge
component of the three-dimensional
aspects of urban Warfare many cities
have cities under the cities and and in
battles like this which this movie is
based on the Battle of Stalingrad which
was called the rat War because there was
such a prevalent
underground yes that's a possible Urban
sniper positions the characters on both
sides are Loosely tied to real snipers
that were prevalent in the Battle of
Stalingrad who were known to like put
themselves in the barrels and the
ventilation shps the cat and the mouse
between the two
snipers that didn't
happen
we do train shoulders to use the
environment and there is some aspect of
manipulating light and smoke that's the
real thing right reflective lights in
the mirror but you don't know where the
sniper is and unlikely that you're going
to have that ability to Blind that so no
don't don't do that I want to give it a
higher one because it is poin out the
underground whipper aspect but the
realism of the actual this happening
around a three I guess
that's pretty about as real as it gets
the IED or the improvised explosive
device is the weapon of the last 20 plus
years the invisible enemy that you
couldn't fight back
against the m250 Cal is still used today
it's a very effective uh large machine
gun that has the size of bullet and
penetration of concrete that you'd want
uh where other weapons might not the
accuracy of what the bullets were doing
to the building looked pretty pretty
accurate some of them you can tell
aren't penetrating he didn't shoot that
many bullets at that wall to create that
level of a sprawling and honeycombing of
that
wall the tactics there are pretty sound
where you have the machine gun covering
an upper level while the Infantry are
maneuvering lower so there's control
there and positioning themselves to
enter that building building where they
know the enemy
is I can't say that that kicking of the
door is not real it's called a mule kick
I wish the movies would stop showing it
because it's not effective but I have
found many soldiers trying it but it's
not the most Force you can put by
kicking in that door you want to face
the door on the ground on
the that's an unfortunate but very
realistic aspect of that scenario and
that chaos when the soldier enters the
room but controlled and not just firing
at everybody but then you have a scared
frantic civilians even approaching you
making the soldier feel very unsafe
that's a very realistic and impactful
traumatic situation that is urban
Warfare so if we were to take out the
mule kick I would give that scene a ttin
g Tim here I'm a former R Marin Commando
that spent time in Afghanistan Egypt
Somalia and just various places around
the Middle East
yes it CS gas which has been widely used
in the Middle East uh especially around
the Arab Spring whether you would fire
it out Motors is is another thing firing
the Cs gas uh and having it air burst
like that would just be like chucking a
little cap of bleach into the sea in
terms of it's Effectiveness on on trying
to poison
swimmers I mean if you were breaking
contact like that you would absolutely
just I would have thought just drove in
a straight line as fast as possible to
get out there uh but they seem to Veer
into it just for I think for the
purposes of the film and for the viewers
really fact that they're perfectly
placed on the top uh is quite comical
really a Minefield would normally be be
set out in a certain way to either
restrict movement or to channel the
enemy into a particular point in terms
of the spacing and the mixture of Mines
it's just been placed there just for the
vehicle just to hit it the
anti-personnel mines actually now banned
by the Geneva Convention what used to
happen with those was you you'd trigger
one of the Pines uh and they they come
out the ground at about waste level and
they detonate but yeah you wouldn't
normally see on on top like that unless
there'd been a Sandstone but even still
they look brand new if you were breaking
contact or trying to get away from the
enemy in an open desert like that with
no kind of life support you've got no
Urban environment no uh buildings you
would absolutely want to stay in that
truck unless it was completely disabled
and at that point you had no other
option but to leave it because it was
acting as a magnet for the enemy but you
certainly won't bail for it from it if
it was uh if it were
moving improvised explosive devices that
have used in like Iraq and Afghanistan
do flip vehicles but whether a mine
would be able to flip it to that extent
is is debatable but certainly the people
that were inside it would be severely
injured if not killed I'd give it a
three yeah they're in the desert they're
in military vehicles there's military
kit getting used but apart from that
it's very Loosely based on reality
iic located at
the moving and forming up in your
configur they're really really closed up
now before they got to the Border when
they were driving in urban areas or
built up areas that kind of Convoy
posture would have been perfect you want
to maintain the posture and the security
and not have vehicles come
in but as soon as I've kind of left that
and they're going now into the open
desert and open ground that would want
to really really extend the space
in the hum V is it's it's an awful
vehicle it's it's not comfortable during
this now you would close up because
you've got limited visibility it's
exaggerated there really yeah is it is
it is a thing it would it would restrict
your view absolutely no no osar one
incoming on your right there I see
nothing contact right I think it's
realistic you would have put out contact
right contact right which is what they
do again it's good there's like natural
generalized chatting there about the
weather and and whatnot that would
happen in real life uh there'd be some
jokes there'd be some banter uh but you
would be very much focused on the job at
hand so the communication there in terms
of communicating to the whole group is
is is is good it could be a bit better
but it's good I don't see
anything
you would absolutely at all cost want to
drive through that we call it driving
through it they call it the Killing Zone
to stop in that or be disabled in that
would be like your worst
nightmare the sound and the impact that
that round would make on the windscream
I think would naturally despite your
training just make you do that I think
once a few rounds at it and it had
massaged your anxiety of nothing's going
to come through you would like to think
that you'd be able to get back on track
and and push through that just it's
chaos it's what's called a complex
attack the first guy's got out to the
left which is what you would do on a
contact right you would get out on the
left hand side of the of the vehicle and
use it as cover then to try and get some
Rams off if you if you had to you're
always told and trained to get out of
the side naturally that's not taking a
fire so you'd get out to cover and you
can see how they're kind of getting the
weapons into the shoulder and now than
manipulating the doors and then pushing
the door and coming back onto the stock
of the weapon and stuff it's it's really
like high level stuff and weapon
manipulation and use of cover it's it's
it's absolutely
superb I wouldn't want to be under there
as a as a soldier because you'd have no
view whatsoever of anything that's going
off and it would be claustrophobic I can
see why she's done it unmilitary trained
but uh it's not where where I'd want to
be you've got to try and get away from
that Killing Zone somehow as soon as
possible I i' give it nine the only kind
of thing that lets it down really is the
spacing when they're going into open
ground in terms of the vehicles but
apart from that uh how they react the
weapon manipulation the
communications is is really
good he's running around often with a
top off or a vest on the Sunburn and the
heat stroke that it would get from that
would kill him you'd have like some kind
of a camouflage shirt on or like a
tactical jacket like a like a thin
jacket and you'd almost certainly have
body hammer
on dependent on the sand sometimes it's
it's it's soft and it would be
incredibly difficult to move I mean
granted he's got no kit on no no body
armor but it would be incredibly
difficult you running from side to side
to evade possible enemy fire especially
if that's coming from from behind you
you'd be running two positions of cover
rather than in a straight
line
it's there to look like a hind uh it's
actually a the pumers that have been
modified they've been mocked up to look
like real Soviet gunships yeah they were
introduced uh I think by the Russians in
1972 so they definitely would have been
in the actual Afghan uh and Russian war
in in 79 to
89 the biggest myth really is I think
about desert Warfare films is I think
the Hero Journey that one takes so
if you look at say like Rambo or or
anything like that it's it's kind of a
oneman band one person getting injected
into into a theater into a into a war
zone and in reality it's just it's it's
wholly not
possible that weapon system 50 cal duska
it would take it down it absolutely
would and I'm just slightly unconvinced
that there would be eight enough rounds
for it uh for that amount of time time
sometimes you can get one or two rounds
off then you have to start doing your
stoppage drills one person could operate
that year would be better with two but
one person could it's a difficult one
because everything that happens is in
the Realms of possibility uh it really
is uh I would probably give it five I
think the percentage of success that he
would get from doing what he does would
be very very small call it and see if
they're friendlies in the area Lima to
Charlie Li Char the radio operator has
tried to establish coms via the sa phone
it's not been successful but he's not
give the responder opportunity to
respond we've used them before in
Somalia and and other places it's just a
case of sometimes moving to an elevated
position or a different location to
establish communication they are
unreliable who are they here I don't
know you would have automatically hit
the floor and gone to ground and you
would have started observing from what
we call your belt buckle from your from
a prone position the miral effect
obviously it's a thing it's there but it
wouldn't distort the images like that
and you'd still be able to make people
out and their movement towards you it's
very relaxed they're not running they're
not shouting you'd be looking for
weapons or weapon systems as they start
to get
closer one my line they do get into
extended line which is good tactically
for this scenario but the posture that
get into the Hostile posture getting
weapons and and getting them ready to go
into the shoulder is an escalation that
you would want to try and avoid see
they're all M16 they've some of them
have got underslung grenade launcher
attachments it's an old American issued
weapon there'll be real weapons with
probably just magazines in with no
ammunition what are you
doing
s guys cover
him weapon should have been down for
sure they should have had like one of
them just put his hand up but just
posing a more peaceful kind of approach
maybe saying like the local language in
terms of a welcome would have been would
have been the right course of action to
take he walks straight into the arc the
the line of fire of all the lads he
would never do that he would have almost
certainly been killed in that if if it
would have gone gone ugly realism I'd
probably give it about a five or a six
it's not uncommon for people to walk
into your Arc of Fire or your line of
fire and just be unaware of
it
in this instance you would try and Scar
her away to cover in a low profile going
to ground in straight away is is good
drills try and lower your profile but
trying to get into some form of cover
would be ideal I know it's difficult in
this scene it's it's very open and
there's there's no built up areas or
anything like that your tactics in this
would be to if you have to engage engage
but then try and peel away yeah' be
worst case scenario you go it's a minime
that that the guy's got here which is
like a key Tactical Team weapon uh belt
fed 5.56 ammunition but just how he's
holding it it's up and then he holds
holds the back stock he's he's he's
definitely been taught
that the drills in this as well we call
it the rate of fire the people with the
rifles the M16s are like firing single
shot which for accuracy is great A
Massive thing in Hollywood is all
weapons are always on automatic fully
automatic and it's it's not really
correct although the
drills are good and Slick you you in
this you can't get away from the fact
that it looks like act as holding
weapons probably give it a four I think
the SAS in reality would have done
things differently a lot differently I
don't think you would have engaged in
preemptive strike like that unless they
were literally coming toward you in upon
you the dog is is clearly sniffing
for putting the in the ground just to
identify areas to avoid but they might
also be putting the ground just to show
you the Allied Forces where they can
move but they would sit down here when
they've come across something that
they're not quite happy with they're
expecting a treat where it's kind of all
about for them it's just a
game in terms of disorientation like the
ringing noise alluding to like how your
ears would be absolutely yeah you might
not hear anything for for minutes uh
might Bush your air drums I mean it is
realistic but they just seem to recover
too quickly from it could be an old
Shell uh an old warell that they've that
they've used pointing really towards a
vehicle like a vehicle IED that they've
that they've kind of detonated there the
fact that it's actually on what looks to
be like a common trail for vehicles and
stuff kind of points to the fact that it
would have been that I think it probably
might have been a greater explosion a
bigger explosion but it would blow them
back like that if not worse K9 error
would be a factor that you that you
would factor into it especially if
you've not kind of run the dog over that
area as
well hey how did you draw this there you
could have get us all kill it must have
triggered the bomb from those houses
it's all really good until after the
explosion there's no way that you would
be kind of up on your feet and calling
somebody out for what they' what they
have or haven't missed you'd be glued to
the floor you'd be you'd be shocked
you'd be disorientated
uh and you'd just be scared to death
there's no way that that would you would
kind of respond in that kind of manner
and another thing that you've got to
worry about is that might just be the
first
detonation there might be a secondary
explosion and I think if if somebody has
detonated that with a command wire which
is which is what's what's happened you
you would absolutely be expecting an
ambush off the back of that because
you've actually got people watching I
think it's really realistic up until
what happens after the explosion and for
that I'd probably give it a
seven so the red smoke is to indicate
the LZ The Landing Zone where you're
going to extract somebody from slightly
strange in this clip because it's almost
self-explanatory given that you've got
helicopters just above it so it's kind
of just thrown out there probably
visually just for the viewers of this
film it would have been an incredibly
aggressive kind of post you now from the
from the rescuing forces they wouldn't
waste any time trying to decipher
whether you've got weapons or whether
you're a friendly there's just no time
for it it's just quickly in and out so
everybody in between them and uh
extracting the the the the US Personnel
would
have it wouldn't have been a great
experience for him
whatsoever
[Music]
your the Americans or anybody will
always go back for one of their own own
you would have had guys on the ground
for weeks days before providing ctr's
closed Target record of this and
establishing uh patterns of Life what
kind of weapons they've got what time
they go to bed where they keeping the
hostage and if they keep moving him and
that would have been getting fed back in
order to create this this uh this rescue
attempt so the first phase of it
probably would have been the Spectre
gunships that you see and the the
Apaches coming in followed by the ground
forces following up behind
are Marcus the
TR you're safe Marcus you're going home
what they could do is is probably ask
him me service number like what's your
service number what's your name what's
your rank and stuff like that uh which
would quickly identify him so it's true
to life right it it actually happened so
uh got to give it a nine or a
10 got movement 12:00 about 300 M two
guys on the roof are they armed I don't
know so these are US Marines there's
kind of two sides to the communication
at at the initial start where they're
saying I've they got weapons I've they
got weapons it's to identify them as
potential enemy targets but also it
gives them in a sense a free pass to
engage if they after looking for weapons
is is the combat indicator simple
question Trad you see a weapon negative
that's not the question you asked you
asked if they were on the answer to that
one is I don't armed Orga why
else would they be running around up
there I don't know do I I don't
understand people I think the chatter is
is Hollywood it's unrealistic in real
life it'd be it' be very minimal and
especially the swearing as well I think
this is probably a bit tame in terms of
what it would be like real life
certainly the the the immature nature of
it is definitely inaccurate I know is we
need to see
weapons they're not really using cover
well and yeah they don't really move
position in between firing or once they
take that first shot they should have
move position and especially if it's a
sniper as well because i' just be
looking for you just to pop back up in
the same position and he'll be on target
Kevlar elmet they are effective in in in
protecting your head it all just depends
on the caliber of bullet that the
helmet's hit with the angle and also uh
how close it is from leaving the barrel
to it in your helmet if it's a sniper
which you could argue it is from that
range and picking shots off like that
they would have kind of a long caliber
bullet like a 7.62 long firing out of
bolt action rifle it might protect them
based on angle but uh if it is a sniper
from that distance as well they would
probably be getting like hits it towards
the center of mass or or on the face but
it would protect
them what the viewers need to appreciate
is is that it would be incredibly
incredibly uncomfortable to to have your
head above that knowing that somebody's
firing because all you can really think
about is is that in not even a second
you could be it in the face and you that
might be you just completely turned off
so you are uncomfortably aware of that
so I think you would be a lot further
down where are
you I mean he might have had sand kick
up from the from the round that he wants
to just get out it's probably the right
course of action in that instance he
might have had a bit of material from
his helmet if he been shot in the helmet
and stuff so yeah I'd give it a five
just because I think the chatter is kind
of
unrealistic